Just like the Haunting of Hill House, Bly
Manor is stuffed with creepy, secret ghosts
watching events from the shadows.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'll be revealing all the hidden
ghosts I found in Bly Manor,
where to find them, and explaining their connection
to the Lady of the Lake and Flora's dollhouse.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
In the first episode just after Dani arrives,
as Flora shows her around the house and they
go up the stairs, you can spot a figure wearing
a hat lurking in the corner.
This is the plague doctor ghost and you can
see him move his head ever-so-slightly upwards
as if observing Dani's arrival.
The plague doctor is introduced in the eighth
episode when he comes to the manor to diagnose
Viola's sickness.
He's killed around a decade after her death
when he accidentally wanders into the path
of the vengeful Lady of the Lake,
while the manor is being used as a quarantine
location after a plague outbreak in Bly.
You can see him next reflected in the mirror
of Dani's room, after Miles wanders in.
And when Dani is having dinner for the first
time with Mrs Grose and the children,
you can see the plague doctor's beaked mask,
brown coat and gloves just behind Miles and
in front of the dining room door.
He seems to quickly disappear once the camera
moves to a wider shot.
Later after Flora has finished her bath, she
opens the door to her room and you can see
the silhouette of the creepy ghost.
Then, after Dani tucks Miles into bed, the
doctor reappears inside the bathroom.
And when Dani walks through the bathroom,
you can see his reflection in the mirror.
As Dani puts Flora to bed, the plague doctor
can be seen hiding near the window in her
bedroom.
Later that night, you can spot his beak-shaped
mask in this shot here as he silently watches
Dani coming out of the kitchen;
and then he's here at the end of the corridor.
The next day, after Miles shows Dani the spider,
he appears at the end of the garden.
Then as Dani and the kids go back to the house,
he's lurking outside the manor in this shot,
at the same time that Peter Quint's ghost
first appears to Dani.
At lunch, the plague doctor appears almost
in plain sight in the kitchen fireplace.
The next time Dani puts Flora to bed, the
plague doctor is watching on yet again, this
time from the corridor.
And when Miles comes to ask Dani for a fan,
he's back to lurking in the bathroom.
This next appearance is very slight, but you
can just spot his hat reflected in the walk-in
closet room mirror here.
He also later watches Dani emerge from Flora's
room after she was locked in the closet by
the children.
And then at the very end of the first episode,
the creepy profile of the ghost appears in
the garden.
There's a spooky moment in the second episode
when Dani descends into the basement to recover
Flora's Lady of the Lake doll.
As she turns off the light and leaves, hidden
in the pile of discarded old dolls, you can
spot the Doll Face Ghost sitting up.
This ghost is the little boy that Flora discovered
playing with her dollhouse.
He gets his name "Doll Face Ghost" from the
mask that Flora took from another doll in
the attic and put on him as she said his face
was unfinished.
The boy became a ghost when he was killed
by the Lady of the Lake during one of her
walks to her daughter's old room.
You can spot his ghost standing at the end
of a corridor on the ground floor while Dani
is looking for Miles in the second episode.
In the third episode, you can just make out
his nightgown here outside the door as the
police officer goes to leave.
And then moments later, he's back in the house
just behind Dani.
The next morning, as Dani's getting up, you
can spot him lurking in the shadows.
And in a super-creepy moment, he appears in
the mirror of Flora's bedroom where he turns
his head as Dani walks past.
And you can see him move his head as he watches
Dani leave Flora's room after she kisses her
goodnight in the fourth episode.
You can also see him crouched in the corner
of the kitchen here.
Which must be one of his favourite hiding
spots because he's back there in the fifth
episode.
And during one of Mrs Grose's time loops,
the little boy ghost pops up behind some furniture
in the main hallway.
Also hidden in this shot to the right of the
staircase is the ghost of the vicar, sombrely
looking on.
The vicar was the second victim who accidentally
found himself caught in the Lady of the Lake's
deadly path.
And he appears again in the fifth episode
in the bathroom between Flora and Miles's
bedrooms.
In the third episode, as the police officer
is leaving you can spot a hidden ghost standing
to attention at the back of the entrance hall.
We don't know exactly how this soldier died,
but during one of Flora's memories, while
she was tucked away, her uncle Henry tells
her about a ghost he once knew at Bly Manor.
"I had a friend when I was your age, too.
In this house, in fact.
He was a soldier, and I was very afraid of
him, until I gave him a story."
We don't know if Viola's ghost killed this
soldier or if he died of some other cause,
however, during the Second World War, the
British government requisitioned large country
houses and estates to serve as part of the
war effort,
and it's quite possible that this soldier
was someone working at Bly Manor at the time
who was unlucky enough to cross paths with
the Lady of the Lake.
He also appears behind Miss Jessel as she
plays with Flora's dolls.
A nice detail in this scene is that the camera
very briefly sharpens its focus on the soldier
doll just before he shows up behind Rebecca.
This next one is tricky to see, but you can
spot the soldier for just a split second when
the lightning flashes in the kitchen while
Rebecca and Peter are talking together.
The soldier ghost also appears again towards
the end of a corridor just after the doctor
who's come to check on Flora leaves.
You'll need to watch this scene carefully
because when the doctor was talking to Dani,
the corridor was empty but after he leaves
the ghost is now there.
And in the fourth episode, he's creepily watching
Dani outside while she burns her former fiancé's
spectacles in the bonfire.
Then in the sixth episode, as Dani chases
Flora up the stairs into the attic, you can
spot both the soldier ghost and the vicar
ghost looking on.
The eighth episode reveals the dark backstory
of Viola and Perdita,
and midway through just before Perdita goes
to ask Arthur to open the trunk, as she descends
the stairs,
the portrait of her dead sister seems to come
alive and there's a little angry sound in
the air.
Some other creepy apparitions that are harder
to identify include these hands grabbing onto
a chair while Mrs Grose and Owen are eating
in the kitchen,
meaning there's a ghost hiding under the table,
and judging by the sleeves, it's probably
the Doll Face Ghost.
There's an unknown ghost at the back of the
entrance hall in the fourth episode wearing
what looks like breeches and knee-high socks.
And that same figure appears in the doorway
of the chapel when the Wingraves arrive home
in the fifth episode.
And there seems to be a ghost lurking at the
back of this corridor which looks like it
might be the Doll Face ghost,
but it's a little too blurry to be sure though
the hidden figure definitely wasn't there
earlier on the same day.
There's also a ghostly figure just behind
Jamie, while she and Dani are out looking
for Peter Quint.
And its long, light-coloured robe suggests
it could be the Doll Face Ghost again.
And there are even more plague doctor ghost
appearances to look out for on top of the
ones I mentioned earlier.
When Dani bends down to pick up Flora's faceless
doll, as she gets up there's a blurry figure
reflected in the mirror that wasn't there
before.
Judging from the brownish colours, it looks
like the plague doctor again.
In the second episode, the masked doctor can
be seen spying on Mrs Grose and Jamie over
here.
And as Jamie comes back in the house, he's
right at the end of the corridor.
During the game of hide-and-seek in the second
episode, you can spot the doctor lurking near
a window in a room where Dani goes to look
for the children.
And during the game, the ghost of Miss Jessel
is watching in the background while Dani's
back is turned.
In the third episode, while Dani, Mrs Grose,
Miles and Flora are talking to the police
officer who's come to investigate Dani's sighting
of Peter Quint,
in the background you can spot the outline
of the plague doctor's distinctive beaky mask
as he observes the scene.
And in the fourth episode, you can spot the
creepy hat and beak crouching by the desk
in the study as Dani walks past with a bottle
of wine.
And there are even a few secret ghosts when
characters aren't at Bly Manor.
It's not immediately obvious, but the backpacker
that comes out of the room Dani's staying
in at the hostel in London is very likely
another hidden ghost.
Notice that Dani's room is for two people,
but only one bed is made up,
and it's unlikely anyone else has been staying
there as she's been using the sheets from
the second bed to cover up the mirrors in
the room.
Another ghost outside the manor you might
have missed is the ghost of Edmund who appears
very briefly in the window of a taxi that
rushes past Dani in the first episode.
I also have a theory that there could be some
ghosts haunting Miles's boarding school.
These two priests in the headmaster's office
while Miles is being reprimanded seem strangely
silent throughout and not really necessary
for the scene.
And when the camera cuts to a different angle,
the priest to the front of the desk seems
to no longer be there.
Likewise, when Miles goes to the school's
chapel to read a passage from the Bible, there's
a mysterious man painting the wall.
He seems like an unnecessary character to
add to this scene given Miles has no interaction
with him, and I suspect he may be a ghost
as well, similar to the clock-fixing ghost
in Hill House.
Like Dani's backpacker ghost, these figures
may simply be there to add to the oppressive
sense Miles already feels from the ghost of
Peter Quint.
An interesting detail is that all the hidden
Bly Manor ghosts we need to look out for throughout
the season appear as dolls when Flora introduces
Dani to her dollhouse in the very first episode.
Notice that Rebecca Jessel's doll is behind
Flora's bed, which is fitting as the ghost
of the dead au pair has been taking possession
of Flora.
Similarly, Peter Quint's doll is hiding behind
the wardrobe in Miles's bedroom.
The plague doctor is in the bathroom exactly
where he appears as Dani walks through the
room.
The Doll Face Ghost is down in the entrance
hall, where he appeared in the fifth episode.
As is the soldier ghost who appeared there
in episode three.
Perdita is in the attic, which is where she
was killed after opening Viola's trunk of
clothes and jewels, and she's the ghost who
Flora tells to be quiet in the second episode.
I haven't seen the dead vicar in the dining
room [as he is here], but presumably he's
lurking around there in a scene somewhere
And Mrs Grose is the doll with the red top
and green skirt.
Sneakily, this doll is an early clue to the
fact that Mrs Grose is already dead and is
actually a ghost at this point, something
that isn't revealed until the fifth episode.
The other three dolls are for characters that
are still alive:
Flora, Miles and Dani.
As we later find out though, Flora and Miles
have already been possessed by ghosts;
and Dani will eventually become possessed
as well by the Lady of the Lake.
Now if you're as creeped out as me by Bly
Manor's hidden ghosts spying on the home's
inhabitants,
you'll find it troubling to know especially
if you're online at home more than ever that
your own internet service provider is also
logging all of your online activity.
One way to block these secret spies is to
use a virtual private network whenever you're
connected to the internet.
A VPN helps protect your privacy by encrypting
your internet connection and making your data
unreadable to others,
preventing your ISP, government agencies or
malicious hackers from reading your emails,
private messages or knowing which websites
you're visiting.
Which is why I want to thank the sponsor of
this video NordVPN who offers one of the world's
best virtual private networks.
One thing we especially like about Nord is
the super-fast download speeds on its 5,000-plus
servers through the use of new-generation
VPN technologies like Wireguard.
And unlike many free and slower VPNs, Nord
has a no-log policy meaning it doesn't record
or retain details of your online activity
when you're connected to its service.
Plus if you're a video junkie, NordVPN can
help you bypass geo-restrictions or censorship
on content not available to view in your country.
Just pick a server in another location and
browse the internet as if you were there.
You can connect up to six devices at the same
time, including your laptop, tablet, desktop,
phone and home router so you can cover all
of your connected devices.
For a limited time, NordVPN are offering all
our viewers 68% off the two-year plan and
a bonus month absolutely free.
Just visit NordVPN.com/Flicks or tap the link
in the video description to access the offer.
That's NordVPN.com/Flicks for a huge 68% discount
and an additional month completely free.
And to discover even more things you missed
in The Haunting of Bly Manor and easter eggs
which connect it to The Haunting of Hill House,
tap here to watch my upcoming video on that
or follow the link in the video description.
I'll add the links as soon as the video is
ready.
So, did you spot any other hidden ghosts this
season?
And what were your favourite details in the
show?
Leave your comments below!
If you enjoyed this, then a thumbs-up is hugely
appreciated!
Next tap left for a full breakdown of the
ending of Bly Manor and what that final shot
with Jamie really means or tap right for something
else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!